i love you like a love song baby i am
from texas grand prairie texas and i am
15 years old when i was about six or
seven years old i asked my mom if i
could be on the tv and when i was little
and she said all right we'll try it how
old are you selena i am 11 years old and
selena's meteoric rise to fame all
started with this adorable 2004 disney
audition you stole the goat stop people
guys it's just a goat
let's remember what's important here
dream boys dreaming at midnight
at the time selena was wrapping up a
two-year stint on barney and friends
alongside another future disney star
demi lovato is the band here not yet i
went and auditioned for barney and um
well that was my first thing without
even acting school or anything and ever
since you know
i've gotten more confident with myself
so i mean i don't i don't care if i
don't get this but it'd be awesome it'd
be a fun experience but you know i'm not
going to cry if i don't get it but i'm
trying to get into my singing career and
my acting career i want to be both you
know i don't know
yeah selena sure conquered her teenage
dreams and more after landing her first
leading role edge bonner youtube
i hear you've got a big project coming
up yes a new disney channel show wizards
of waverly place i'm playing alex russo
she uses magic to get out of situations
just to be on their on their network is
just a blessing and i'm thankful
everybody tells me that it's one in a
million but here's the thing about
disney
well selena practically grew up with the
other disney kids turning 30 this year
demi nick jonas and miley cyrus it
doesn't mean they always got along throw
in taylor swift and you got one big mess
so buckle up
so at the time selena and demi were
besties timmy's my best friend clearly i
have such a connection with her she's
always there for me
enter miley and the love triangle back
then both stars had a thing for this guy
[Music]
[Applause]
in 2008 selena started dating the joe
bro after miley and nick broke up in
2007. i could never watch my
ex-boyfriend mackin on another girl and
stay friends with him that romance
introduced her to her new bff taylor who
was seeing joe jonas at the same time
demi was not happy
the two never got their friendship back
on track in 2020 demi told harper's
bazaar quote i'm not friends with her
[Music]
then in 2011 was the beginning of fever
[Music]
i'm always wanting her to do the best
she can be the two would make up and
break up several times all throughout
jelena was super private about the
relationship is it true you're dating
justin bieber
you know you love me you know you care
just shout whenever and i'll be there
the baby justin
bieber
in august 2016 selena entered rehab for
a second time to treat anxiety panic
attacks and depression as a result of
her lupus she emerged stronger and
selena and the biebs broke up for good
in 2018.
[Music]
you know my personal life and my family
and my friends i'm just i'm in a really
happy place it's been good
selena is now entering her 30s better
than ever
all right i'm back in the game a bit
it's nice despite being snubbed by the
television academy who failed to give
selena an acting emmy nomination for her
hit show only murders in the building
she really killed him she did make
history as the second latina in emmy
history to get a producing nomination
for the show and she teased new music
i'm actually working on it right now
it's just been a little hectic with this
but i'm i am in the studio i'm excited
selena is of course also the queen of
social media she is the most followed
actress and singer on instagram with 337
million followers and she has become the
queen of tick tock i'm totally fine
being single it's a real thing it's fine
selena's tick-tock rule never be afraid
to poke fun of your past like she did
while reciting her vintage interview i
like a little edge and a little pop in
my hair so i wanted to add something
different especially for the teen vogue
party
[Music]
you